et puis surtout là moi je voudrais
comprendre un truc il y a eu un moment
chevelu il y a quelques semaines on est
passé de la team cheveux à la team rasée
qu'est-ce que c'est que cette histoire
expliquez-moi vous ce que vous avez
ressenti parce que moi je me suis
expliqué un petit peu mais je vais vous
expliquer de façon mais qu'est-ce que
qu'est-ce que vous vous avez ressenti
bah déjà je trouve que je préfère sans
je vais pas vous mentir c'est gentil en
même temps tant mieux non j'adore ma
tête voilà je suis très content de ma
tête j'ai pas j'ai pas trop de complexe
pour l'instant ça va bon alors on sait
tous demandés ce qu'il est parti
effectivement dans un pays
méditerranéen pour se faire greffer
quelques poils de barbe sur le crâne
exactement bah en fait c'était vraiment
toute une expérience sociale que j'ai
fait je me suis je voulais vraiment
ramener un coup de projecteur sur la
tournée de mon spectacle
et je me suis dit que j'allais faire la
promo avec des cheveux parce que je vois
que depuis que
ouais depuis bref c'est à dire depuis
que les gens me reconnaissent dans la
rue et tout on m'a fait beaucoup de
réflexion sur les réseaux sociaux comme
quoi j'avais pas de cheveux comme quoi
j'étais comme quoi j'étais bah des garni
mais des fois c'était de manière assez
insultante et assez de manière assez
focus quoi déjà on sent que les gens par
exemple je mets une photo de moi quand
j'étais gamin ah bah tu avais des
cheveux tu avais dit je faisais très
cheveux en permanence quoi donc je lui
dis bon il y a un sujet un peu sensible
visiblement parce que depuis 10 ans je
me dis ça dès qu'on parle de cheveux
c'est ça ça génère quand même une rejet
ou en tout cas une
des critiques vous l'avez sans critique
il y a un peu de poudre il y a un peu de
dynamique derrière les cheveux et je lui
dis tiens je vais apparaître avec des
cheveux et ça va être marrant et on va
voir et surtout on dira aux gens qui me
reçoivent de ne rien dire comme si
c'était normal et du coup je suis allé
me faire poser un complément capillaire
j'ai laissé pousser mes cheveux sur le
côté je suis allé voir un peu les
réactions
et ben voilà je peux me permettre de
juste
en voyant ça je me suis toujours dit
c'est fou parce que ça c'est l'image des
infos vous savez un peu l'Iran quand on
parle de l'Iran en France c'est ça c'est
toujours la première image qu'on montre
c'est ça et moi j'ai grandi dans un dans
un monde où tout ce qui venait de l'Iran
était quelque chose de génial et symbole
de fête symbole de famille de réunion
symbole de langage et toujours quand
quelqu'un parlera rien à côté moi je
suis toujours l'impression que c'est un
membre de ma famille parce que c'est
pour moi c'est quelque chose de très
familial et j'ai toujours j'ai grandi
avec cette dichotomie entre ce qui se
passait en Iran depuis 40 ans qui est un
drame total pour la liberté et pour les
gens qui vivent là-bas et
[Musique]
c'est vrai que ça ça rend un peu
schizophrique de se dire mais attendez
pour vous l'Iran c'est ça alors que
l'Iran enfin moi tout ce que je vois de
l'Iran c'est c'est de la chaleur et
c'est pas c'est pas cette froideur
justement de
me permettre d'avoir une pensée aussi
pour les gens qui sont là-bas et qui en
ce moment sont en pleine manifestation
il y a un humour chez votre papa il y a
des saillies il y a quelque chose
d'artistique je crois qu'il vous a
transmis inconsciemment ou pas
totalement inconsciemment parce qu'il
était totalement contre l'idée que je
devienne acteur ou artiste ça qui est
fou mais il faisait toujours des blagues
en fait il racontait toujours des
histoires du coup j'ai trouvé ça
incroyable qui se trompe pas compte
qu'aujourd'hui là je me prête à faire
une grande tournée où je raconte une
grande histoire je me dis mais c'est
quand même fou parce que j'ai été formé
par le gars qui enfin ça vient de la
base elle vient de là elle vient pas
elle vient pas nulle part maintenant
j'ai un enfant je me dis waouh il va
m'observer il a disparu en 2013 vous
l'avez accompagné jusqu'au bout est-ce
que c'est pas vrai du tout c'était
vraiment que dans le spectacle parce
qu'en fait il est faux
là quand même
alors oui alors pardon alors du coup
c'est juste pour vous déstabiliser
en plus
mais au moment où vous au moment où vous
faites le choix de de carrière qui est
l'artistique parce que parce que vous
leur imposez
j'ai pas le choix de leur imposer de
façon ils ont pas le choix de Me de
l'accepter de l'accepter vous partez sur
Paris vous quittez Reims vous partez sur
Paris avec trois francs six sous en
quelque sorte et les années passent et
il va falloir évidemment prouver ça
c'est
un moment de rupture avec lui oui
complètement c'est quasiment trois ans
de rupture à se parler en
on avait une application c'était ma mère
on passait par cette application et on
pouvait changer des messages sur cette
application donc c'était à base de
beaucoup d'amour mais beaucoup de
désaccords c'était assez fou en fait
c'est fou d'être en amour
pour son enfant et en amour pour son
père et d'être en qui font des accords
sur le quotidien et même un truc que je
vais aller loin je vais aller plus loin
là-dessus c'est que je suis content
d'avoir fait ce choix aujourd'hui alors
que que il y a des énigmes c'est cool il
y a des trucs mais j'étais très content
de le faire à l'époque devant trois
personnes c'est pas le c'est pas le
sujet mais je me dis
si j'avais été avocat il aurait été
hyper fier il aurait pu dire ouais mon
fils est avocat le sait ce petit moment
où on dit mon fils avocat mais
aujourd'hui qu'il est aujourd'hui il est
parti il y a enfin j'aurais été avocat
pour qui du coup j'aurais été avocat
pour lui pour ce petit bourquier ce
petit moment mais ça m'aurait pas
vraiment rendu heureux et là aujourd'hui
ça j'étais très heureux vraiment je me
rappelle le jour 1 je suis arrivé à
Paris faire du théâtre au cours Simon
j'étais le mec le plus heureux de la
terre je me suis dit sur le tournage de
bref si ça marche pas
bon bah il y aura le stand-up il y aura
tout ça mais vraiment je mets tout mon
cœur là dedans c'est un peu un cri bref
c'est vraiment un cri du désespoir c'est
tout ce qu'on a écrit là-dedans c'est
c'est nos noirceur les plus profonds des
choses avec lesquelles il faut enfin
faut se battre pour améliorer sa vie
pour essayer de comprendre les choses
qui vont pas qui vous emmène vers la
dépression d'ailleurs le personnage de
bref terminant dépression c'est un peu
la morale de l'histoire si si vous avez
un parcours comme le
c'est un parcours que j'ai eu et voilà
il faut savoir se
c'est de se remettre en cause
aujourd'hui parce que vous avez fait
effectivement une dépression vous l'avez
raconté toujours c'est un
violoniste
il y a pas les mêmes cordes en fait
c'est comme si il y avait il y a une
corde un peu plus aiguë normalement dans
le violon
ouf ah c'est un très très bel instrument
de location en tout cas vous avez pris
bravo félicitations c'est assez minable
je veux dire NON NON
voilà là c'est un là
[Musique]
ouais je joue un peu ouais ah oui
[Rires]
[Musique]
voyez il y a un truc que ça raconte
c'est que ça ne souffre pas de la
moindre fausse note dès qu'il y a une
fausse note au longtemps c'est fou et
moi ça fait longtemps que j'ai pas joué
donc du coup j'ai perdu mon son c'est
dommage mais non enfin vous l'avez vite
retrouvé là quand même enfin en tout cas
de nous qui n'avons pas fait 15 ans de
conservation non mais ça raconte bien
c'était une fausse note bah oui
évidemment mais le son le son d'un d'un
instrument c'est vous savez
[Musique]
[Rires]
ça ça a une chaleur mais si je le
bossais tous les jours ça aurait une
vraie vraie vraie chaleur et c'est
quelque chose qui ne c'est du sport de
haute compétition en fait les gens
doivent s'entraîner tous les jours et
c'est vrai que j'ai un plus grand
respect pour les gens qui ont fort un
métier parce que c'est vraiment une
grosse abnégation de soi c'est 5 heures
de travail par jour pour arriver ces
mots passants qui disait ça 10 ans de
travail pour être un musicien passable
je trouve ça très juste bref ça va
revenir pour une nouvelle saison alors
comme ça la question au dernier moment
c'est une excellente technique mais
malheureusement je peux pas répondre à
cette question mais bien joué bien joué
là je me suis détendu j'ai eu un petit
cadeau et au fait bref ça va revenir
bien wesh